[Applause]
foreign
how about you had to drink tonight
one or two
all right here once you step out and
come back with me real quick
are you the Richard owner
the dealership
okay
okay all right all right step on that
real quick
um yeah step one I'll come to the back
yeah
I apologize
no no more it just sit right here
towards the front of my car right there
give me one second to cut these front
lights
all right
you can lift you sit right here in
Brighton Hall
[Applause]
you said you work for you say you work
with the Cavaliers okay all right so
again reason obviously what we just
talked about
um you said you had one or two tonight
YouTube all right so we'll put you
through a few fields sobriety test all
right do you have any um any recent
injuries any leg injuries hip back lower
back injury anything like that
um anything wrong with your eyes no
recent concussions or anything
so what you do is you can't put your
hands arm down to your side feet
together
all right I want you to follow the tip
of my pan okay
okay all right once you try to follow
the tip of the fan but don't move your
head just follow with your eyes your
eyes on okay you ready
just try
[Applause]
really
five zero three degrees
[Applause]
please
okay
that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
all right I got a couple more feel
sobriety tests for you okay
um
this is called the walk and turn test
all right
[Applause]
your car okay and so all we're gonna do
is I want you to imagine that
that you're um
foot is on that yellow line if I mean
the foot is on that line between where
you are now and the back of your car
okay
it's an imaginary straight line between
where you are now in the back of your
car okay so I want you to pretend like
your your left foot is on that imaginary
line and put your right foot in front of
it touching Heel To Toe
go ahead and do that for me around
comes out to the side with you stand
like that while I explain this test to
you okay it's called the walk and turn
test all right when they tell you to do
something have you uh take nine Heel To
Toe steps straight forward
when you get your ninth step you're
gonna leave your front foot forward and
you can take nine Heel To Toe steps
straight back okay while you're doing
this test you're gonna count out loud
okay I promise you I'm the president of
the Cavaliers
hi
I just got back from overseas trip as
well so I'm also exhausted it's had a
long dinner
I mean I'm trying to I understand I
understand the test yeah I'm just trying
to
work with you on I was trying to get
home
but I mean the reason I stopped you
because you're almost caused an accident
right I don't think I mean
I get that it was it's like try to get
in front of him to go to the left lane
I've driven multiple times I know
exactly what I was doing I don't think I
caused an accident I didn't say you
caused one I said you almost caused one
right he was paying attention he swerved
and moved out of the way you're going
you're flying coming up behind him but
he he moved over so I was going to take
that lane I understand
so how fast do you think you're going I
don't know but I wasn't going over the
speed limit
this annual system
I mean we know we're in this we're
you're talking about something and I'm
talking about what happened you're
talking about something that didn't
happen you're talking about you're not
going over the speed limit and you're
flying up in the past in the past Lane
the guy then you try to cut over and the
guy sees you he swerves and moves out of
the way
I don't understand I don't understand
but
okay
again walking turn tests all right
um
I didn't think to get anything yet okay
all I want you to do is put your right
foot take your hands out of your pockets
please put your right foot in front of
your left
Okay Hand start down to your side all
right just stand like that while I
explain this test
can we do that
all right so now that music didn't stay
that way but then okay and that's fair
enough what I tell you to do something
how you take nine heal the toe steps
straight forward when you get to your
ninth step you're gonna leave your front
foot forward and you'll do a pivot turn
maybe you're gonna take nine heels uh
steps straight back in this direction
okay while you're doing this tester I
want you to count out loud one two three
four five six seven eight nine You're
Gonna Keep Your Hands arms down to your
side and you're going to be looking down
at your feet while you do the test okay
only other thing I want you to do is
once you start the test don't stop do
you understand that
so
don't I don't want you to pause in
between yourself there's nine Little
Steps all right I'm gonna demonstrate to
three okay
when I tell you to begin you'll begin
one two one
of your front foot forward take Tiny
Steps around and come back one two three
again I went to three for demonstration
you're gonna go to nine wait a minute
sir do you understand the test at all
you have any questions about the test
back in the starting position first
hands like this right foot in front of
the gun all right if you don't have any
instructions and you understand the test
go ahead and begin whenever you're ready
one two three start with you and show
you that make sure I'm good no I can't
you have to do the whole test
I'm coming out tonight yes
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
all right we got one on the chest serve
you can face me go ahead and face me my
hands drops down to your side okay feet
together
just say like that while I explain this
first test okay this one's called the
one leg stand text when I tell you to do
so I'm gonna have you raise one foot off
the ground approximately six inches
right down in front of you like this
you're going to point it down slightly
and you're going to look down at it and
you're going to count in this manner
1001 1002 1003 one thousand four one
thousand five okay just gonna keep going
until I tell you to stop okay it's a 30
second time test
give me one second
[Applause]
you just take your hands out of your
pockets for me I appreciate it
[Applause]
all right so whenever you're ready you
go ahead and begin to use either foot
that you want either either leg you want
to balance on
how long it's a 30 second time test
30 seconds if you happen to put your
foot down just pick it back up on the
number that you left on okay like I can
do
[Applause]
no well the goal is not to put your foot
down I'm just telling you if you do just
pick back up on the number that you left
off again hands are on down to your side
feet together no no to the side you
gotta raise one foot
as long as they keep it balanced
well in your Sport's supposed to be
easier to keep your mouth no no it's hot
Oh I thought it should be easier so wait
a minute so you're going to raise it off
don't forget you're going to be looking
down at your foot okay so make sure
you're looking at your foot during the
entire test
wait wait wait wait wait don't get the
practice to see that no practice no
practice whenever you're ready go ahead
and begin
[Applause]
look at your foot sir
look at your foot very good
you're messing me up oh you're supposed
to be I gave you the instructions just
let the test keep going away I can't
hear you counting
how did I mess you up because I'm I'm
focusing
oh that's that's good enough
all right so you've been arrested for
Obi before
have you ever been a restful VI before
no
it's way right here for me okay thank
you
[Applause]
foreign
no you should refuse it
all right turn up put your hands
together if you hatch back like you're
praying pulling the Palm don't step up
here a little bit
not right this second I'll get it for
you
just put in Palmer Palm like that
foreign
take your watch out for me
[Applause]
all right sir you want to rest for OVI
yeah they might write the main side of
things
you also have the right to stop here at
any time you also have the right to stop
earrings at any time until you talk to a
lawyer you can't affordable you won't be
appointed for your party in the
questions